I love what you said about rejection
sometimes when I'll do you know I'll
watch videos or I'll read about an actor
or a writer or a musician I find that
actually some of them that have really
thrived they had a very painful early
rejection and I'm just wondering does
that almost because you had that first
early painful rejection any new
rejections it's like okay casting
director didn't like me well my own
father rejected me so what could be
worse you know so I see that sometimes
I've seen I've actually looked at a lot
of people's lives nothing like wow that
person I really admire they grew up in a
tough situation and I'm wondering if
that almost helps in some sense I think
your ability to deal with pain and how
you deal with that determines your life
journey yeah every rejection and this it
sounds crazy but every rejection is
painful but it's not personal
of course the 20 people before you are
rejected also they weren't rejected
because they're not talented and you may
be more talented than the person who got
that job not because they're more
talented than you but because in this is
gonna sound crazy because if you have
50,000 social media followers and they
have 5 million because it's a job so
it's not personal and it's not meant to
be personal it's business
they put 5060 million dollars into the
movie you may do the same very well but
that other person is gonna bring five
million eyeballs so just suppose 10% of
them buy tickets that's 500,000 tickets
for opening day you know and it sounds
harsh but I have a question if you put
50 million downwards or 150 million
dollars into a film when you be
interested on the ROI of your investment
I mean you may love Henry but if Sam can
bring you 50 million eyeballs for the
hundred and fifty million you've spent
you're gonna think about it so we think
they're mean and horrible people No No
thank you for watching our interview
with Bill Duke for those of you who
enjoy this content and live in Los
Angeles we invite you to experience film
courage live we have two upcoming events
this Tuesday October 16th we have a
filmmaking panel with filmmakers
Christopher Rea Andrew P Jones Royce
Gorsuch Orson Ovitz and Brian Aven and
Bradley and on Tuesday October 23rd
we have a one-night-only class with
Pamela J Smith entitled mythic
challenges creates stories that change
the world we are excited to host both
events we have links in the description
below if you would like to attend